so hello everybody and welcome to this
free webinar
on computational biology and
bioinformatics
today we have a few speakers who will be
sharing
their story on how they came to be
interested in this domain
and how they are using it in their
research we hope that this will help
some of you
see a path for yourself and ask any
questions you might have
from these students researchers faculty
or industry
experts and what they could recommend
for you
first we will hear from our research
fellow sonalika ray
who will share her project update on
liver cancer drug resistance and drug
repurposing
she is working on her master's degree in
bioinformatics and has joined the
research fellowship program
to complete this project then hear from
dr laura harris and her student amber
park
they will speak about their stories of
how they got interested in computational
biology
and what opportunities exist in
computational biology for teaching
research and education
after that our team will share their
perspective
on how they got involved in
bioinformatics dr
mazumdar will speak about bioinformatics
tool development as well as
how research projects lead to
applications in research
and industry then dr kaur and clinton
kuna will speak about their background
in collaborative projects where
bioinformatics methods and big data
are a bridge for academia and industry
working on
cancer but before we hear from them let
me briefly introduce
everybody joining here to omixlogic
so my name is deepsha biswas and i'm the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
who are managed by pine biotech and are
part of our bioinformatics community
at find biotech our mission is to
simplify bioinformatics for students
clinicians and biologists
and we do through this through our
training programs known as omixlogic
these omixlogic bioinformatics training
programs are running in five different
regions with over 10
000 users around the world our training
is designed to allow participants to
apply
methods to curated new data sets and
develop
independent projects that showcase what
has been learned in the context of a
personal portfolio of projects
as a result anyone starting on this
journey in bioinformatics can start
developing a project of their own
in fact we have already worked with many
students who have completed this kind of
training and developed
interesting research projects that have
won awards and got published in
peer-reviewed journals
i would now like to invite sonalika ray
who is a master student from the punjab
university to share with us
more about the project she is working on
so over to you sunalika
thank you beepsha i'm not getting the
permission to share my skin okay thank
you so much
is my screen visible yes so nalika we
can see your
screen okay so a warm greetings everyone
i'm sunali khari i'm pursuing masters in
bioinformatics from punjab university
chandigarh
i'm a research fellow at pine biotech
and today i would like to share my
research progress
on my project analysis of hepatocellular
carcinoma transcriptomic data for drug
repurposing
so before i start with my progress i
would like to share about myself and
what made me
join find biotech research fellowship
program
so as a research scholar i developed
keen and trust in omix data science
computer aided drug designing and for
macroinformatics
and i wanted to learn more about the
omics field and apply
data science techniques to it so i came
across this wonderful pine biotic
course where i could learn each and
everything even in the my newest
of the ways though i just signed up for
one course but
ended up taking more of the courses and
was fortunate enough to join the
research fellowship program
and now i'm doing my own novel project
under the mentorship of doctor hub
herpete so yeah if you are a research
scholar
to and looking for good courses do check
out their knowledge back
i especially wanted to mention one more
thing so from last three years i kept
running the program of
like i just kept running from the
programming languages
it haunted me like anything but after
going through the omics logic platform
and the
program course for different fields now
i feel confident
and yes now i can run my own analysis
with r
so first of all i would like to give a
basis of my project to you
so starting with hepatocellular
carcinoma which is also abbreviated as
hcc it is the second leading cause of
cancer related mortality globally
it is present in patients with chronic
liver inflammation which is associated
with viral infection
alcohol overuse or metabolic syndrome
hccs significant progress has been made
in
fcc prevention diagnosis and treatment
in the past however
more than 50 percent of all hcc patients
have a diagnosis at an advanced stage
and 70 percent of patients relapse
within the first five years of initial
treatment
uh early hcc is often resectable but
advanced scc often requires sora finite
for systemic treatment in addition to
local treatment with ablation trans
arterial chemo
embolization or external irradiation
so there have been many drugs which were
proposed for sora
or like for hcc hepatocellular carcinoma
but it was just the drug surfing which
is
approved by fda in the usa
but there is one problem solar offender
that later stages of hcc
shows resistance in some of the patients
not some but many of them who have been
taking the uh
the medicines for a longer time of more
than six months
so surah phineb is effective in
improving the outcomes of
hcc patients in the late stage
initiating a period of
robust clinical research so as i told us
resistance is seen in many of the
patients after a few months in the late
stages of xcc
let's have a look at what are the
mechanisms of sorafen of resistance in
fcc
so what is surapping it is basically a
multiple target tyrosine kinase
inhibitor
it exhibits anti in geogenesis
anti proliferation effects and extended
total median survival in advanced hcc
patients
it suppresses tumor cell proliferation
by inhibiting rafa and b
rap and kinase activity in the ras rav
mek erk signaling pathways it is capable
of targeting
pdg fr beta wedge fr2 c
kit and other proteins to inhibit tumor
and geogenesis there are drugs like
uh lenguating rigorophile gabaso
xanatip and ramucerumab which have
received approval
as second line treatments after
surabanic
my knees is uh being used as a
first-line treatment but these drugs
have been approved for the second line
treatment
okay so immunotherapy for fcc has not
yet
been approved in china or germany
and the sorophenib remains a cornerstone
treatment in hcc
that is supported by robust evidence and
clinical experience
however 30 percent of the patients they
get benefit from surah in it and this
population usually
acquires a drug resistance within six
months as already two
so it has been seen that the role of
epigenetics transport
processes regulated cell death and the
tumor micro environment
in the initiation and development of
soda finite resistance and etc
so you see there are a lot of factors
which affect this orphan of resistance
so my plan of action would be to take
the cell line
then match the gene expression
alteration in resistance uh hcc with
gene expression changes which are caused
by
treatment of cancer cells with drugs
which are already approved by fda for
other diseases
then identify the drug that can reverse
the resistance related changes
then identify the mechanism of action
that is the pathway or the drug target
involved of the drug against
sse and provide proof of concept
evidence
for the validity of the drug repurposing
approach
with potential use in personalized
medicine
so i took different sort of data sets as
i just told that there are a lot a lot
of factors which affect the
surface resistance in fcc so i took
four uh like eight data sets in total
and these eight data sets
had different sort of factors right so
i just highlighted those factors so
there was this mrna
expression comparison so up in a
resistance related circular rnas
then the third dataset showed acquired
resistance with epigenetic alterations
something show transcriptomics
and other data set was related to dna
methylome then we had
nupr1 which was a new target which was
found for liver cancer
the fgf signaling role stocks
and stock sign knocked out so uh
here i've just shown uh the r outputs
for one of my data sets just to
give you guys a hint of what actually
i'm working out
so this is the data set for the
circular rna solar net resistance here i
had two groups the first one was
sensitive to surface
another one was resistant to surface and
then i found
a regulated gene that was this one it
down regulated genes and this is the
volcano plot which shows
uh the down regulator genes and the up
regulated genes
and then we have the heat map right
so what i did was i took all the
all the data set performed differential
uh
gene expression analysis for all of the
data sets
collated all the information and then
got all the upregulated and the down
regulated genes for
each and every data set right so this is
uh what
my up regulator jeans and down regulator
genes look like
i copied them all took it to uh
integrated
links uh web server for connectivity
analysis
integrated links workflows integrate
vast omics data resources
and a range of analytics and interactive
visualization tools
into a comprehensive platform for
analysis of omics signature
and signature driven drug repositioning
right and also i got gene networks from
uh gene mania so gene mania is a tool
itself in eye lens
and here i uh like i can see the
interactions
of each and every gene which i mentioned
in the upregulated and the down
regulated
uh gene list so i am
interested in the gene sox9 because yes
it uh
is very much crucial in the sr hcc
pathway
so the knockdown of sox9 was seen
to suppress the activity of surapna
resistance in scc
so i would want to uh actually
down regulate this particular gene and
then try
to see the effect on my pathways
whether soda finite resistance gets away
and my hcc samples become sensitive
again and also then we can have a look
at whatever genes
are interacting with the gene sox9
itself
then i took all the lists of up and down
genes to l 1000 cds square
and i queried my genes against the
reverse effect
for net resistance again and i got a
list of perturbations
and here one thing which is important is
the overlap score
so here i would be getting these overlap
scores which actually refer to the
input differential expression genes and
the signature differential expressed
genes
divided by the effective input so what
i'm doing i'm just scanning
all my differentially expressions
against the
diff against these two differentially
expressed genes in the
database itself right so after doing
that
i i i got a very beautiful plot where i
could visualize
the reverse effect of genes so here in
the rows
i mentioned my upregulated and the down
evaluated genes
so this red label refers to the
regulation
and this blue label uh refers to the
internal revolution
and as i'm looking for the reverse
effect that is if i have the up and down
regulated genes
i actually want to reverse their effect
using
any sort of perturbation right so that
the uh expression of that particular
gene becomes back to
normal right and in the columns are my
perturbations
and these red bars as
columns with the perturbations as longer
actually
refer to the score so these particular
perturbations have a good score and
these particular perturbations have a
low score so yes i would be taking into
account the perturbations with higher
score
i analyzed these perturbations uh with
higher scores
uh like uh i and i analyze them using um
pubchem and then drug bank and then try
to see
if they actually pass or not the
important cad properties and yes the
uh so i got three particular hits and
here is one hit which i can like i have
mentioned here everything about it
so this particular head brd k92317137
shows that it actually passes and
satisfies each and every property
and then i could uh take this particular
perturbation to end lecture
and look for the gene interactions of
this particular molecule
with other sort of genes and here i have
the
overlap and the target so target is
something like
what particular genes this small
molecule would target
and what expression would give like how
would it affect
those particular genes so this molecule
is going to
dominate down regulate for example uh
fox
1 and so on and then i could also
check the drug gene interactions of this
small molecule
in the pubchem and then take this
particular compound ahead
for further analysis okay so uh one
thing more like what i did here was
instead of taking everything all the
data sets
results and collating them i just took
up one particular data set
and tried to analyze it and from
that particular data set i got a
lot of perturbations again and again the
higher scores were mentioned here so i
took up give it a name
as one of the perturbation and wanted to
analyze it further
so give it a faint filipino but yes
passed more of those
rules and then i tried to find out its
mechanism of action
and the target genes so that was it
and now i'm looking forward to actually
look at how these particular small
molecules
interact with the genes and how they
affect its mechanism
and how then those genes would be
interacting with
other sort of genes and how the pathway
would be affected
so uh hopefully next time when we meet i
would be here with the
whole of the conclusion and that's it
passing it on to beeps
and yes if anybody has any sort of
feedback it's most welcome
thank you sonalika yes so does anybody
have any questions for sunalika
you can either write your questions down
in the chat box or
even unmute yourself and ask at this
stage
so thank you again sonalika for the
wonderful presentation and i really wish
you
all the best for this project
so sonalika is part of the research
fellowship program so the research
fellowship program
has been designed to help young
researchers
and students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources for
analysis of complex high throughput life
science data and become versed in
bioinformatics
the program offers to you to participate
in real
and cutting-edge bioinformatics research
and be part
of a renowned bioinformatics community
and here is a link in the
chat box so we have a question at the
moment from gopal so sonalika you can
probably
share those links in the chat with gopal
what are the tools used for your study
thank you gopal for the question
so next i want to introduce you all to
dr laura harris
dr harris has a long history of working
on research
with students and is now the director of
training
at the michigan state university we
wanted to invite her to share
more about her background and allow you
to ask
any questions you might have about
computational biology for those coming
from a biology
life science background so over to you
dr harris thank you
awesome uh thank you very much for the
invitation
i'm really excited to be here so um
my bioinformatics story this is a
different kind of presentation for me
because usually i'm used to talking
about my research
uh things about sars or mrsa
or other things regarding antibiotic
resistance or antimicrobial therapies
i'm usually not talking about myself
so um as the introduction stated i'm the
director of training for the institute
of cyber
enabled research at michigan state
university
i've been in that position now for about
three months and i'm looking forward to
three decades in the future i'm also the
founder and principal investigator of
the harris interdisciplinary research
group
which i started back in 2015.
it is primarily a bioinformatic research
group but we have bled
over into basic wet bench experiments
and amber can talk more about that if
you have questions
and then i am the elected president for
the michigan branch of the american
society for microbiology
and i also sit on their council for
microbial sciences where i advise their
oh
now worldwide board so i've gotten to
listen to dr
fauci talk and a few other high-profile
microbial biologists
i thought it would be nice to just give
a timeline of
my career and i'm highlighting this in
particular to show you that a good
majority of my experience is in
experimental biology what we typically
call
the wet bench i have been everywhere
from
petri dishes all the way to pre-clinical
dermatology at pfizer
through clinical trials uh and fda
documentation
new drug applications investigate sorry
investigational
drug applications that sort of thing um
and i had a very brief
experience with bioinformatics very
early in my career but i really didn't
pay attention to it
until circumstances later in my career
dictated that this was a good approach
for me to continue research and so i'll
discuss that in a moment
so where did i start well what you see
on the right side is
literally my student id as an
undergraduate at michigan state
university
it's a little blurry but it was issued
in may of 1998 so yes i am dating myself
probably the only time in history a
woman will actually do that honestly
my goal at the time was to attend
medical school i wanted to become an
md or a do i had two internships at
william beaumont hospital in royal oak
michigan
and i had transferred to michigan state
as a junior
from a very small knox college outside
of
michigan uh my second semester at
michigan state i met dr julius jackson
now dr jackson has now retired uh
and i worked with his wife who's also
now retired
but they were microbiologists and they
were just starting to get into the
idea of computational biology and using
a computer
to help with experiments so i had him
for an undergraduate class i think it
was pro carryout physiology
it was a fun class and so he recommended
i look at this new program that was a
combination of a bachelor's and a
master's in microbiology
this was going to be my fall back if i
did not get into medical school and well
as you can tell by the initials after my
name i did not get into medical school
but we started with a traditional
experiment research with petri dishes
and bacteria
and looking at what genes affected what
amino acid production
and then we ended up switching to a
computational approach
mainly because the focus of my program
had changed at that point
so i graduated with my bachelor's and my
master's in microbiology
so i already said i didn't get into
medical school so my backup was to go
into
medical based research and i loved it
i spent a few years at bioport who is
now
emergent biosolutions making the united
states only anthrax vaccine so i did
research and development for that
i moved on then to pfizer where i did
pre-clinical dermatology
compound development a lot of acne and
alopecia medications a lot of pigs
because that was our champion it's got
the skin closest to human
and at that time i was doing more higher
level administration
for um study directors rather than
dealing with the animals directly
but i was allowed to go on the floor so
to speak
and see what was going on so after
having about four years of
experimental industry experience i
decided i wanted to become a study
director
at pfizer i wanted to work with my
administrator friends
and the only way to do that was to get a
terminal degree so i went back to
get a phd in cell and molecular biology
so i started as a graduate assistant and
we were doing
inflammatory bowel disease in pediatric
mice looking at bone formation and how
ibd affected their bone growth
and then i had my first child my second
semester in
and so i put this here for many reasons
one because of elon musk quote that once
you have a family
you're not just thinking about yourself
you take risks for them
and this was a picture taken by my
husband at the time
because he said this is how he most
frequently saw me
asleep because if i wasn't working at
the lab
i was home studying for qualifying exams
and other things and it took its toll
so i decided about two years in that
this was not
for me and that i really didn't want to
continue doing what i was doing it took
me away from my kids and from
my family and so i said all right let's
switch gears and i dropped out of that
phd program with
a masters but i wasn't done by a long
shot
so then i started teaching and so i
started as an
online adjunct teacher because i could
stay home
and still maintain my role in science
because i
love science and medicine so i taught
for university of phoenix for a while
rasmussen college she was now a
university and then university of
phoenix invited me to start teaching
part-time in person
all over michigan they promoted me to
lead faculty area chair of health and
science
and then as things progressed i
eventually became part of davenport
university
who desired excuse me decided to hire me
in as a full-time instructor
so at davenport my primary
responsibilities were to teach
biology a lot of it to mainly to nurses
but once in a while to science students
like amber as they decided to
to pop up on my radar uh and so a lot of
teaching six
seven classes a year sometimes more
most of the time it was introduction to
biology or human anatomy and physiology
pathophys microbiology lecture and
lab all sorts of things but then as
i progressed i got to teach more
computational stuff like data analytics
and bioinformatics
but i'll get there i was also a science
lab coordinator so i was responsible for
preparing all the campus labs
so for promotion as a faculty member at
davenport i needed two things
i needed to demonstrate professional
responsibility
now that could be anything from
publishing in my
field to giving talks like this one
etc i also needed a terminal degree
great there's that stupid phd thing
again
so i'm gonna have to go back and it was
lucky for me that quite a few of my
colleagues at davenport were also going
back a few of them were getting their
phd in educational leadership
others were getting their ed in various
administration but that was because
davenport is a teaching college
it's not a research college like
michigan state is michigan state is
known
worldwide for its research capacity
davidport's just getting started
i think amber's what class number four
out of all of our science uh classy
essays she's saying yes
so you get the idea they're just
starting in research
so remember my overall goal was to
attend grad school i got to get a
terminal degree
and become a study director
i didn't want to teach i wanted to do
i'm a huge proponent of people
learn by example people learn by doing
so i can't teach science research if i'm
not out there
doing it hopefully alongside my students
so i took a whole different approach i
wanted to go for a phd
in a science but that meant i would have
to quit my job and leave my family and
basically move back
into a lab for five plus years and again
i wasn't willing to do that
so the response was to get a phd
in biomedical informatics and i was
lucky enough to find
rutgers university had an online program
that allowed me to do just that
so at the same time phd
is a group of mostly davenport undergrad
nursing students but then it expanded it
became only the nursing students but the
science students and now the alumni that
still won't leave even though i love a
bed well they're still here years later
but you get the idea and we started with
one student just repeating that
simple project i did back in 2000
and then expanding on that project and
then asking well can we apply this to
medical stuff
what about antibiotic resistance oh well
there's a spin off from something of
laura's dissertation but didn't work can
we make it work
and one student became two students
became four students became
15 freaking students i was going nuts
and we had poster after poster until
eventually we had wells of posters
and then we started winning awards by
the spades
so here's amber actually winning one of
her first of many different awards
my very first student michael herrani
winning one of his
um he graduated a few years back we were
honored at all sorts of leadership
conventions and uh you know excellence
in business dinner gala at davenport
uh the chamber of commerce of michigan
and i've even been now to national and
international conferences where i've got
to hung out with or hang out excuse me
with um
nobel prize winner like i'm showing
francis arnold here next to me from
2019. so it has been a ride
that no one ever expected because i
wanted to do research
i would not give up on doing research i
had
no money for a wet lab but computers are
relatively cheap
so what do i do now well interestingly i
started at michigan state university
of teen 20 plus years ago and now i'm a
faculty
at michigan state university so it's
kind of interesting to be literally in
the same building i've earned degrees in
um i'm the director at training at icer
and so my job
now is really three-fold i teach
courses primarily to other resource
researchers excuse me i teach graduate
students i teach
post-docs and i'm basically teaching
michigan state researchers why a super
computer is important towards their
research and
how they can use super computing in
their research
along with things like basic programming
computational reproducibili
reproducibility excuse me bioinformatic
tools like you saw on the project
earlier et cetera
i'm still doing bioinformatic research
so amber and i
are finishing up some papers on stars
that
are somewhat complementary in method to
what you saw earlier which was cool
but we're also you know antibiotic
resistance we've got a pseudomonas
project there's a multi-drug resistant e
coli
project there's a strep project
and we've started branching into all
areas of microbiology so
microbial induced cancers uh we've seen
well sars came up recently and kind of
unexpectedly for
us and now i'm getting a broader
audience at michigan state
so things like climate change how can we
model that how might climate change
affect wa
rock weathering patterns can we predict
that
that sort of thing and of course public
outreach you know inspiring people to
join bioinformatics or computational
anything at this point
so this is what i do nowadays so um
if you have any questions if you're
interested in
working with my research groups you know
amber
is uh going to be heading off to medical
school she was able to do what i did not
so i will miss her dearly but anyway my
email address is here it's austrai
msu.edu it literally is the same email
from 20 years ago
um and i'm happy to hear from you so at
this point i guess i'll
turn it over to amber and then we'll
take
questions thank you so much right before
that could ask a question
actually uh oh sure you mentioned that
you were exposed to bound from after
your
during your undergrad and uh that kind
of
faded away so i wonder what was that
first
impression that you had was it i'm
excited to learn more and use this or
was it this is something useful but i
don't know where
like what was your initial impression um
honestly it was intimidation so
i felt comfortable with dr jackson
and the lab but i did not feel
comfortable as a programmer
so i had taught myself basic at that
time and i knew enough to like be able
to count nucleotides and amino acid
frequencies and basic stuff
but then there was a phd student scott
harrison
um no relation to my last name but
he actually was like a hardcore linux
programmer
and so working alongside him i kind of
felt i was better at the lab
part than i was at the computer part and
it wasn't until
i got older and really needed the
computer for research that i started
saying you know what
that insecurities in your head get out
of your own head
and now you hear me talk about that all
the time about
you know i still have insecurities that
i suck at programming and my husband
will frequently tell me
stop with the self-probation you're
actually somewhat
good at it so that was my initial
impression
got it thank you very much
i'll entertain more questions later yeah
thank you so much uh dr harris for this
wonderful wonderful presentation
i'm sure that everybody has enjoyed it a
lot and we have
dr harris's email in the chat box i've
posted it so please feel free to
reach out to dr harris if you have more
questions
and now i want to introduce you all to
amber park
she's a bachelor student and she has
been working with dr harris
on research projects that led her to
become interested in buying for matrix
and even earn awards and opportunities
to present
her work so amber over to you
thank you hi guys yeah thank you so much
for coming do you want me to present um
a powerpoint or
yes please go ahead it's completely up
to you thank you
so as laura mentioned um i'm a current
undergraduate at davenport university
i'm going to be graduating this semester
and going to be attending lincoln
memorial university in knoxville
tennessee
i started with laura back my freshman
year when one of my
peer students he actually introduced me
to what laura was doing
and i thought it was a great opportunity
i never really was a
big computer person but i now i'm taking
the actual course
and i find it's very interesting because
it's a different perspective than most
people believe i'm more of a hands-on
person but it teaches me
a lot about what you can learn about
biology through different ways
um as she's mentioned i have
been at many different conferences for
laura do you day of research she
mentioned
along with mism van andel and even
northwestern
i am still working on the covert
research with laura and we are in the
moment working on the paper being
published
and going to start a new one as well and
we are
looking to present at world micro
inforum
hosted by asm as well
and so a lot of people ask why and how
this bioinformatics
in involved in my life and how does it
really change me and i
i think it's very different from
learning what you
do in the classroom to actually applying
it because with laura i
saw a lot of processing with involving
metabolism
um actual defensive mechanisms and so on
and
you learn things at a very 2d level and
so when you're actually applying it
the concepts become more real life to me
and i think that was very valuable along
with just
being able to polish my presentation
skills for moments like these which i
think are very important
continuing to build my network in
creating general personal relationships
because
in the future i know that being able to
know those people and to be able to
interact and build these social
skills and presentation skills is very
important especially as research is a
huge and crucial part in just general
the science field
so i think that it's great that i was
able to be involved with laura and she
has taught me a lot and i'm very
grateful for
her support and her help and always just
mentoring me as
these past four years so
and i think that bioinformatics is very
important as
we all know that technology is growing
at the moment that it's a huge part
into how we treat patients and also how
we research in general
and so just being able to be familiar
with these computational programs i just
recently
kind of got touch of python not a big
calm side person but
it's very useful and i think also the
publication opportunities being able to
publish an actual
paper under my name is very impressive
to me and i'm
very proud to be able to be part of
laura's work and i said
as i mentioned before just having
general networking skills and
presentation skills and being able to
actually apply
this knowledge that i learned in the
classroom too problem solving situations
and learning more so i think that it's
very useful to
go out and try different types of
research and also to involve yourself in
different opportunities
because you never know where it's going
to take you and i've learned a lot from
laura and she's
given me so many different opportunities
to present and disseminate
the information and research that we are
finding at the moment so
and that's my talk for today
thank you so much amber for sharing your
story with
us it was wonderful to have both of you
join us today
and again if you have any questions for
amber or dr harris please continue to
post them
in the chat box and now i want to
introduce you all
to my team member dr mohit masumdar
he is an experienced bioinformatician
with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journals
and collaborations in
industry and academia over the past
several years he has been developing
collaboration with
universities as a mentor and project
lead for omix logic training
and research programs so over to you dr
mazumdar thank you
thank you hello everyone
and thank you dr laura for that
wonderful session and thank you amber
and sunalika for sharing
their presentations so to everyone
joining for the first time
my name is mohit mazundar and i have
completed my phd
in computational biology and i've been
working with
academia and industry to solve important
research problems
so in my current role i'm working with
students who
so as i was telling you that in my
current role i'm working with students
who are keen
uh to you know in do research in
bioinformatics
and are from high schools and are
undergraduate students
from all around the globe as well as
researchers for bioinformatics research
uh interest and their need to complete
their own research projects so
well i do have other responsibilities as
well
but i'm really happy to be an active
contributor
in this exciting world of discovery so
today
in my presentation i would like to tell
you all about
my research experience and my
bioinformatics experience
so uh when i started i guess
bioinformatics
uh or having a degree in bioinformatics
meant like
developing tools or by developing
algorithms
which involved a lot of coding so
certainly
the challenges were different than now
so
being here for a while i guess i can
talk a little bit about
how things have changed or evolved so
starting from the data the algorithms
and the ease of ease of applying those
two projects
have become like now a matter of you
know
a matter of getting started so it's a
matter of choice now
so for my project which you can see on
the screen
i haven't i have had an interesting
question
in hand which is to be able to
functionally annotate
sequences using data that has been
generated by scientists
and then to develop predictive models
for unknown sequences so what i was
trying to do was you know to
kind of develop a machine learning model
so it
i thought it was interesting because in
this current era of high throughput
generation
high ngs sequencing where there is a
large amount of genomic data is
generated
every day prediction of gene function
and their detailed annotation have
become a key aspect of computational
genomics
so that's quite evident and i it has a
great importance
in the aspect of doing the right
annotation so the focus of the study
uh here was to annotate uh calcium
binding ef and
motives uh and then classify them based
on their binding affinity so these
motives play a critical role
and there are proteins like uh
calmodulin maybe
many of you have heard about that
protein so it plays like a
major role in a lot of functions so uh
so as i was telling you like how i
started and i kind of
faced some weird problems so well they
sound more weird now but when
i joined i had i have had a data set of
just 90 sequences right and that was
exciting because the labs that
collectively you know sequenced and
developed these contra
con constructs uh by performing itc
experiments
and then by getting the estimation of
binding affinity
so um they kind of have already spent so
much money
doing all of that that they were totally
expecting
me to you know kind of develop a
predictive model that was like kind of
in their
part of their proposal for the funding
so what i was trying what i was trying
to tell you is that
i was under a lot of pressure and like
they were expecting me to do magic
but after struggling and trying to apply
um
neural network uh nothing worked out and
i was getting like very
bad sort of numbers for predictions uh
prediction of binding affinity so the
accuracy finding like an accurate
numbers for the
uh for their uh stuff that they have
already you know kind of generated from
bit lab experiments
so during a lab meeting uh i said that
even after doing all of this and trying
this for six months
i don't think it's possible to predict
binding affinity and they have had a
uh you know correlation coefficient of
0.46
so point less than 0.5 so it was really
really bad
so then i think my pi who is like
completely
awesome supported uh my hypothesis
is that of that we should collect like
all the data from different
labs and uh because like the different
labs they do
do use different machines and over the
period of you know time
the technology has evolved so the the
data that has been generated in 1990s
might not be as accurate as the data
that has been generated like you know
uh 2015. so there need to be some sort
of normalization that needed to be
developed to you know kind of
get these predictions uh to be uh in a
right
maybe these predictions are maybe the
correlation coefficient between
the function and the sequence to be you
know corrected
so after so five years later we were
able to publish this
and uh let me tell you uh like those two
years
between these five years were just
rejections and revisions
and i was really i really got upset at
that time and perhaps like
sometimes angry after reading some of
the speculations that people have
had about this bioinformatics based
research
so that was way back way back and uh
because
it's it was kind of something new and
something that was
uh proposed it was difficult so
uh after that i think uh whence once uh
it got published i was kind of
determined to prove this hypothesis
correct
because going through that entire phase
and
we kind of ended up doing some
experiments uh by crystallizing the
protein structure
by by doing those mutations that like
the server predicted to be like high
high affinity mutations so we did the
mutations by
applying side uh directed mutagenesis so
what i'm trying to tell you here is that
uh i mean combining uh buying
bioinformatics
applying bioinformatics and then i mean
validating it
using wet lab so it's a nice combination
and i've seen this
being published in a lot of like good
research journals
because then you're kind of validating
what you have done
and now like uh i see how the way
the science and also the bioinformatics
has evolved in
the sense that now we have big data and
with big data the biggest advantage
is that like we are considering
thousands of gene we are considering the
entire pathways
so our hypothesis is much more stronger
and the results that are coming from
thousand experiments rather than one
experiment is obviously much more
conclusive
so as you see in this in this in this
figure on the right that we
we kind of ended up showing that how the
in mechanism
in the structure this actually affects
and changes things
so we kind of showed them that uh that
these
entire residues up after mutation they
show a different pattern than the wild
type where the structure
and the communication between the
residues has changed due to some
mutations in one site
but it has also changed in the other
side so we kind of ended up making this
hypothesis that both communicate each
other
through this uh through these residues
and we kind of did some pcas and some
uh you know computational biology stuff
over the results of uh the the
app results to make it like a complete
story and with
a lot of insights so uh what i'm trying
to tell you is that
that uh going through this entire phase
and time period
i do realize that what challenges
students face
what challenges researchers face when
they kind of try to compile and
kind of want to finish a research and do
a good research
so during this phase uh what i thought
is uh have been helpful and has been
really amazing
is that i've been able to uh during this
time i've been able to communicate with
a lot of scientists and discuss
talk about my research discuss about
their research and
like apply how bioinformatics can help
in
whether you know to design an experiment
or to analyze results from an experiment
and that led to a lot of uh development
of skill sets which
which helped me to uh you know use
multi-dimensional aspects
in my own project so by working in
different different sort of research
questions or
by looking at different kind of research
questions that what people are working
on
and what kind of methods they have used
it is kind of helpful to you know put it
in another context of your own question
so literature review and like putting it
in context of your own research question
is kind of very important so in that
sense that
what we have been doing and i'm being
really
honored uh to be able to part of this
team
where we are actually directly trying to
make bioinformatics much more accessible
and uh going through this entire
research journey
so as you know that the biomedical and
the health care and
industry is evolving now rapidly uh
similar to the space research so we have
had like this kovid situation and now
things have different
now people are more aware and there are
more experiments there are more funding
so however i mean that have been only
possible because of the technology that
has enabled researchers to you know
generate
volumes of data in much easier and
simpler and efficient manner
and and it's still an ongoing process
because it's just happening every day
right
so by learning about the system and
integrating data
um understanding the biology and to
interpret
this with critical component of this
training and this
logic i think we've been able to work on
much of like translational research and
understand
like how biomarker discovery works how
clinical
in clinical settings how clinical data
is used useful
uh for therapy selection so we've been
working on research projects that kind
of addresses
uh those translational changes which are
like really playing a key role
in today's world of discovery so we are
also working
with partners and other uh universities
and research students and groups where
we have defined like a syllabus
uh which covers all this important
aspect of drug discovery
data science into into one uh
one sort of place so uh where you can
start from you know
drug discovery to talk about a disease
or to
talk about a problem you can start
thinking about the
in the context of data that how data
plays a can play an important role in
generating in generating that hypothesis
as well as proving that hypothesis is
correct so
uh i just wanted to show you that this
is an upcoming program that we have
designed
where we are working with uh several
partners
and several industry leaders so it's an
industry driven program where we are
like kind of
uh created a curriculum
which uh which is exactly uh
you know designed with the help of uh
experts who are working with
pharma so this is a pharma driven
project
where we we are going to go through
genomics transcriptomics data science
and then the deep of like uh chemical
space
so how how chemistry is playing a role
in this entire
drug discovery uh pipeline
so with that uh i would like to thank
everyone
for listening to me and also uh if you
have had
any questions or have any questions
please go ahead and like put them in the
chat or you can ask me directly here as
well
thank you
thank you so much uh dr mohit and as you
are continuing uh there was a question
from
ramon so do you think it's it is hard to
do relevant research without an
academic position
so this is a very good question ramon so
i think uh
what has changed and as i was telling
you that before
if i have to do some real research i
would have to be dependent on an
university for a university or a
research lab or a company so because
that's where you get an infrastructure
and that's where you get like uh
guidance to be able to do this
and the amazing thing that has changed
and the amazing thing that we are doing
is that like uh getting you that
experience
right from like online so we have like
cloud platform
where you can do the real research by
generating you know going through that
easy to do pipelines
so maybe you can show them in the later
part of this presentation
uh but uh how we are helping them is
like we are using this
several tools several topics and a
research methodology
so that you can actually do cutting-edge
research by your own
and if you are motivated enough if you
are interested enough and if you
if you think that there's a good
research question that you can address
then we will be happy to help you
thank you so much dr mohit for sharing
with us about your experience
now i wanted to introduce everybody to
a little more of omits logic so the goal
of a romex logic program is to provide
training in bioinformatics enabling
independent research guided by mentors
and peer example
and this program is right for high
school students to researchers so we
teach everybody we work with everybody
and we collaborate
with our omits logic program and what we
try to do is grow
a bioinformatics community so it's more
about developing a community
which has this shared idea of working
with bioinformatics
understanding what data science is so
this is what we do as part of omex logic
and we help enable students clinicians
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop
novel and independent research using
latest technology in life and data
sciences
so the omics logic programs are
comprehensive training programs for
students researchers and clinicians
who are interested in omics data
analysis so as you see on my screen here
are some of the
omics data types that we offer training
on and we help researchers or
even young students complete their
research on
so the basic programs like these are
designed to introduce various types of
data
methods and context for omics in cancer
neuroscience
infectious diseases and agrobiology
after finishing the basic training
many continue to apply what they have
learned to an independent project
that is called the research fellowship
program
where in part of that program you can
work with mentors
who are expert in these fields to get
guidance on project design
and technical assistance with completing
project for a poster thesis or
publication
now i wanted to show you an example
urja parikhya was able to complete a
project on glioblastoma
and have now published a preprint to
receive
more feedback from the scientific
community
similarly de lara de can an
undergraduate student at the bartesian
university in turkey has also completed
her project on
astrobiology and received a certificate
of excellence from the omits logic
research program
so as you can see we have high school
students
to undergraduate students to phds who
are working on these
research projects and getting started
on their own research journey now let me
introduce you to the mentors
of the program we have dr harpreet kaur
who is a certified omix logic trainer
and expert bioinformatician she guides
the hands-on sessions
and assists our participants with
projects and analysis
during these omics logic research and
training programs her era of
specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
and now i would like to invite dr ford
to share more about her experience with
us
so thank you dr core and over to you
thank you vipsa
hello everyone my name is hatred kor i
have a phd
in bioinformatics focused on liver
cancer
before that i had done my masters
in molecular biology and biochemistry
from guru nanak dev university
marissa india during my post graduation
i learned molecular biology and cancer
are complex fields and there is enormous
genomics data generated
every year for thousands of the patients
across the globe
so bioinformatics can offer numerous
approaches or techniques to analyze
such a big data to drive biological
meaning from that data so after
qualifying my csir
exam after qualifying my csir that is
junior research fellowship national exam
in india
i joined dr gps raghva's group at
csir institute of microbial technology
and dr raghav is one of the key
bioinformatics scientists in india
i feel lucky enough he took me as his
phd student he is not just a dream
mentor
for any phd student he is also a great
scientist
and amazing human being with lot of
patience
to deal every student so patiently
so the sporting ambiance of my phd lab
made it
quite easy for me to turn my molecular
biology knowledge
into the bioinformatics research
projects
my phd research was on biomarker
discovery for diagnosis
and prognosis of the liver cancer using
bioinformatics techniques
so including my mentors my phd boss and
apart from my seniors helped me a lot to
learn bioinformatics
particularly how you can apply all the
techniques
on the data and how you can actually
learn programming
which is very simplest especially if you
are coming from
wetlab background people thought
programming is like
very difficult thing but my lab mates
actually and my mentor uh teach me
that bioinformatics is the simplest
thing if you are just
interested to learn about it
now let me give you some glimpse how
bioinformatics can be helpful
in identifying signatures or a biomarker
for a specific disease condition here i
am taking an example from my
own phd research work
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer for my
doctor research is this high mortality
rate
of this malignancy and lack of precise
biomarkers that can help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
worldwide it is considered as sixth
major cancer in terms of
incidence and fourth in terms of
mentality
next i went through the literature to
understand what are major challenges in
the liver cancer
so here when i going through the
literature
so i have done my first project
that is i have developed a comprehensive
resource which is cancer liver
it maintains 115 gene expression data
for nearly 9 600
samples of the liver cancer along with
there is comprehensive
information regarding already existing
600 mutated biomarkers for the same that
are available in the literature
so in the second project we use
large scale transcriptomics data to
identify
diago diagnostic biomarker panel for
hepatocellular carcinoma
in this study as i have already compiled
the data in my first project so i have
taken
that data and i uh we have employed 30
data set which containing nearly 4 000
sample to
elucidate transcriptomics biomarker
panel for the diagnosis and the
prognosis of the liver cancer
implementing various statistical and
bioinformatics
techniques in the next project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data to identify biomarker panel
for the stage classification of liver
cancer
as it was reported in the literature if
cancer is diagnosed at an early stage
then there are the survival rate of the
patient is quite high
because their number of the therapeutic
options are available
so here we employ tcca data of 350
samples and elucidate 51 features
that include 30 rna transcripts 21
methylation cpg sites
using a number of the data mining
approaches here
particularly the nay based model is the
top performer
that able to classify early and the late
stage sample with nearly 79 percent
accuracy
in the next project we used
transkeptomics data
to scrutinize the diagnostic biomarker
panel
for the chalengiocar cinema which is
another major reliever malignancy
in this particular study we used
nine data set containing 350 plane
geocarcinoma
130 adjacent non-tumorous 90
assists sample to scrutinize plenty of
carcinoma specific transcriptomic
signatures
employing various bioinformatics
techniques
like we have applied various machine
learning
methods like extra tree random forest
logistic regression etc
so eventually in a conclusion overall in
this
study in the first part we have focused
on classifying scc
from the normal samples and identified
three gene based biomarkers
similarly in the second part we have
identified ccs pacific signature which
include lam c2 itc and c3
and in the third study we have tried to
classify early in the least these
samples
and we have identified 51 or multi-omics
features
and at lastly we have also tried to
identify
signature that can actually
significantly stratify
high risk and low risk free occurrence
group and that work is still in
communication
so in my during this journey it looks
like maybe it was very easy so it was
never like that
uh my first paper psp paper is
came around my fifth year but in that
one year i have
almost my 12 papers get accepted so in
my final year sometimes for any phd
student
or any researcher it was very difficult
to keep that patience
so during that work so i have learned
that
to be a phd you need to
you need to very patients but you should
not
lose your focus because you need to work
on
everything and never give up on your own
uh
on your top research so sometimes your
publication not get got
accepted immediately but if you are
working on that so
all your publications are usually got
accepted in one day so
that's all so uh already
currently i am uh since in the year
uh since the september 20 year 2020
i have joined fine bio nephine biotic
team
where i have uh i'm mentoring various
students
so to conduct different projects as
already beeps i have shown there are a
number of the research fellows
who have completed these their research
projects
they are graduate student postgraduate
as well as phd students
so that's all if you have any question
so you can reach me
thank you so much dr carr we look
forward to your continued support
and helping us out with any questions
that we have i've posted dr carl's
email id in the chat it is supported by
not bio please feel free to reach out to
her with any questions you may have
and now i want to invite clinton cooner
who is joining us
as one of the omix logic bioinformatics
trainer
he has a master in bioinformatics from
the university of guelph
and a masters in cellular and molecular
medicine from the university of
otawa so clinton over to you
thank you
so my name is clinton kuno i completed
my bachelor's degree at carnegie mellon
university
where i discovered my passion for
research later on i decided to continue
learning more about life sciences and as
a result of that
i now have two master's degrees one from
the university of guelph and one from
the university of ottawa
since i was interested in translational
bioinformatics i did a masters in
bioinformatics
after completing my master's in
molecular medicine
therefore i am familiar with both
biomedical research and data analytics
so my specific interest is cancer
[Music]
so my specific interest is cancer and
it's an extremely heterogeneous disease
we we are learning more and more about
this complex condition
with greater molecular definition than
before
and to show you how complex cancer is
let me give you an insight
of any of my past research experience at
the university of ottawa
there are several proteins that play
different roles in certain cancers
or certain contexts for example slk
or c20 like kinase plays an important
role in cellular
processes such as proliferation
migration and apoptosis
it affects embryo development and is
shown to play a role in tumor genesis
this was studied in new induced mammary
tumor
mouse models the experiments showed that
slk knockout mice developed tumors
faster and showed an increased
expression
of sox10 an important biomarker in
cancer
however branching from previously known
results on
slk in my own research we've we studied
slk in mouse embryonic fibroblasts where
slk knockout reduces
focal adhesion turnover it turns out
that slk plays different roles depending
on
the particular context even though this
contradicts the other study
it shows us how complex the biology of
cancer can be
and how careful we have to be with
experimental design
and data analysis to truly understand
the pathogenesis of particular
diseases research on
slk is ongoing which is similar to
cancer
every cancer is different and it's a
challenge to determine where those
differences
exist we need more advanced methods to
determine why
a knockout reduces a process in one
context
but increases it in another
my master's thesis gave me a glimpse of
how bioinformatics
can be used to study oncology
and um and the skills i acquired enabled
me to
use more sophisticated methods of data
analysis
such as machine learning to address the
complexity of high throughput data
generated from these types of basic
cancer experiments
so after doing my first masters in
molecular medicine
i realized that i decided to do a second
masters in bioinformatics
to learn complex data and now
analytic skills pure biology is good
but having the data analysis skills to
create meaningful
relationships definitely solves major
problems
that can be translated into applications
within medicine
bioinformatics has exposed me to other
fields
due to its interdisciplinary nature such
as statistics engineering and
mathematics
my passion for biology programming
and teaching led me to pine biotech
as an omics logic bioinformatics trainer
for the biome
pine bios pine biotech's precision
oncology program
i enjoy going through important
pipelines that can be relevant
to my learners individual projects
i personally believe that i've
contributed to my learner's research
when i answer their questions
i enjoy working in the field of cancer
therapeutics
and i'm grateful to share my passion for
the field
as a as a master's graduate in both
medicine and bioinformatics i truly know
the transition
from basic research to bioinformatics
therefore i hope to make that transition
as easy
as easy as possible for my learners
there are several courses on the
omixlogic website
that that has expanded upon
different topic topics within
bioinformatics
teaching these courses helps me become a
better bioinformatician
due to the lesson preparation which
involves a great deal of understanding
of the course material therefore i look
forward to teaching
future omics logic alumni
so if you have any questions please let
me know
thank you so much clinton for sharing
with us
it was wonderful to hear from your
experience as well
and please post any questions if you
have for clinton right
in the chat box and i shall then
continue to
introduce everybody to the various
resources
so today we have heard many examples
from our experts and students alike
learning to leverage bi-informatics to
advance their careers pursue research
interests and discover
new skills that they will continue to
use for the future
to continue to interact with all of the
people you have heard today
and other similar minded students and
professionals
we welcome you to join our community
and dr harris had already shared her
linkedin with you
so please go ahead and find us on
linkedin this is the linkedin group so
let me
quickly get the
link for you okay i think
my screen was somewhat frozen here so i
will just quickly
go ahead and get that link for you so
this is our linkedin group which i'm
posting right in the chat box
yes sure abdul so clinton if you can
kindly post your
link in the chat box your linkedin
profile
it would be wonderful you can reach out
and i've also posted again dr
harris's linkedin profile and i will be
sharing
our facebook groups as well today we
also had this session
going live on our facebook channel so
yeah so let me get back to my
presentation
i'm sorry for not sharing my screen and
quickly get you
through with some of the resources that
i wanted to talk about today
so what i wanted to introduce everybody
to
is the program resources so many of you
have asked you know how do i get started
with bioinformatics
so that is exactly what we do at prime
biotech help people
get started with bioinformatics so many
of our students are coming from
different domains
by biology biotechnology computer
science
so to help everybody get started we have
recently launched a portal called learn
omix logic
so let us quickly go to the website
together
so yeah okay so this is the learn
omixlogic website if you are there
on the website with me please put number
one
in the chat box
so gopal to answer that question what
type of programming knowledge we need to
know for bioinformatics
if you're just getting started you do
not need to know any of the programming
languages
and in fact i'll be taking you through
some of the courses
where you can easily learn about these
programming languages like
r and python and this portal the
learn.xlogic portal is
the way forward where you can easily
learn about it so how do you get started
so if this portal of course you have to
log in to create an account
now i will just be showing you how to
just do the sign up very quickly so if
you are there with me on learn omix
logic can you please put down number one
in the chat
and if you already have an account then
i know that you can
miss any questions from anybody please
post your questions again in the chat
box
so i'm already logged in here so i will
be using my email id but you can also
log in with any of these social logins
so once i log in i'm taken to the course
page where you will find
different courses on different topics
so there are some projects that we have
designed for you
so these projects are taken from
published
or publications peer-reviewed
publications and then broken down
into different sections from where you
can learn about these different steps
that
these researchers have taken on
completing a project like this so what
was the question and what
are they trying to do as part of the
analysis is what these projects help you
with
so these are some of the projects where
you can understand from there several
projects on oncology
on covet 19 also infectious diseases
like ebola
as well as we have this python tutorial
so this python course is
somewhere where you can get started if
you're somebody who's coming in for the
first time and have
no idea there is a course on r and
there's a course on python
and you do not need to install either of
these softwares into your machine
those are code blocks which are built
into these courses so please feel free
to start with them
but i wanted to introduce you today to
the first course which i think
every beginner should start with so we
have this course called
introduction to bioinformatics right so
this is the course that i want everybody
to get started with so if you're just
coming in
and learning about bioinformatics if you
want to
learn more about bioinformatics or if
you like clinton want to transition
to buy informatics then start learning
about what are the opportunities in
buying for matrix
and again this platform offers you a
free registration so once you register
on the learn.comics logic portal
you will have a free registration or a
free level for the rest of your
registration process and then there
would be some
lessons which would be requiring a
subscription
so that subscription could either be
acquired by
taking that subscription option or you
can also join one of our omixlogic
program that gives you access
to the full learn.omicslogic portal
so please go ahead and complete your
registration and then you would be able
to go ahead and
learn from these several courses so this
is one of those courses that we
definitely
recommend you to go ahead and take a
look at and if you continue to explore
this page
you will note that there are several
other courses so you see there's the our
course
there's a course on metagenomics
similarly we have courses on
genomics and transcriptomics and also we
are working on this course called bites
and molecules
which is designed for very very
beginners especially high school
students who are just getting started
with learning bioinformatics and biology
so please feel free to look around the
platform and learn from this
now for those of you who are getting
started
or wanting to get started with their
projects if you go and click on this
research option
it will take you to our research
fellowship page
so what do we do as part
of this research fellowship program so
now let me explain this to you
in a moment
so as you know the journey to completing
an independent research project
is long you will first have to learn
about a particular topic
then review databases for specific
project data set
acquire the skills to analyze it in the
established educational systems around
the world this process can span years
as we have heard from our speakers today
and is highly dependent on your access
to the right faculty
resources and mentors who can guide you
in this process even when the project is
complete you might need someone to
review the outcome
and provide you with guidance to improve
the research results
unfortunately this also means that for
many students and graduates there is a
lack of opportunity to develop and
complete an independent research project
at all that is why so many are turning
to online opportunities where
bioinformatics and data science provide
an opportunity
for a flexible schedule in cutting-edge
topics to conduct
independent research so we offered this
opportunity as part of the research
fellowship
program and this program is divided into
these six stage processes
so we've already seen one of the
projects by research fellows so nadia
curry
so this training starts with self-paced
training using the big data analysis
tools coding in
r and python as well as basic courses on
statistical analysis genomic data and
various topics in biomedicine
agriculture biotechnology and infectious
diseases
in this phase you will either get on a
one-on-one call with your mentor and
assess your interests current skills and
objectives
to identify the right courses for you to
complete so that you are ready for an
independent project
as well as meet every week with your
group
of research fellows who are also working
on projects of their own to learn
from their projects and exchange ideas
as well as collaborate
in the second stage of developing a
project
you have to pick up a competitive topic
conduct literature
review find data prepare metadata for
research
question and then plan the full analysis
and this training also happens in group
sessions where you will see peer
examples hear from the mentors and
experts on
how they have tackled these steps and
use a guided process
to make sure that the plan is executable
and successful
then we ask all of our research fellows
to keep a virtual lab journal
to track their progress so leveraging
our automated system of learning
progress together
with a personal journal helps you to
monitor
your growth and effectively get guidance
from your mentor
and document your journey just like any
researcher would do
in any academic lab next is performing a
systematic or
exploratory literature review our
community of expert mentors have been
curating data from thousands of
online data repositories to help you get
started
with minimal time wasted on promising
but incomplete project examples
we review publications develop
collections of
impactful studies on various topics and
design a system
of semi-independent projects
next is developing a research project
presentation
after the completion of your analysis
your mentor will help
shape up the presentation of your
project so that it is concise and
effective
so i want to show you some of these
examples
of our research fellows who have
successfully completed their research
projects
so i will be sharing the link again in
the chat box for you to review
so these are completed presentations of
research projects
once somebody completes either the three
months or the six
months research fellowship which is the
time that
we offer this program for of course we
can customize it if someone needs
to work with us for a longer period of
time but generally what we see is that
within the three months
or the six months time period you are
able to come up with your own
complete research project so here are
some of these examples of
research projects done by the research
fellows we have already given the
example of
urja who had completed her project and
you can go ahead
and watch these videos and learn about
what are the approaches that these
participants or these students have
taken there are also researchers who
have done such projects
and how they want to take that research
or what are their goals with that
research
in the future so once a presentation
like this
has been completed we will invite
experts in bioinformatics from the tober
bioinformatics research center to
provide
expert feedback on the project using
this
project review you will be able to
improve or consider expanding the
project for further research
this time we will help guide you to
identify poster presentation
opportunities or peer review genres that
might be a good fit or target
finally our team will compile a full
research fellowship report and highlight
your achievement on our social media
channels
for exceptional projects we will invite
you to further seeking opportunities
where you can introduce the projects
to potential hiring managers or academic
bis
so if you're again interested in joining
a program like this
this is the registration to the research
fellowship program
and please note that all the details of
this program
is mentioned here and again here we have
also broken down the different steps of
this process so you can
register by filling out the form here
today
and please make sure to select the
number of months that you would be
interested
in in doing a project like this so once
you have
mentioned that you are interested in
either a three months or a six months
project we will be reaching out to you
and working to identify
the research topic that you're
interested in then
then you work with your mentor and
complete that project
and i also wanted to introduce you to
another program that we have coming up
and also dr mohit has already
highlighted that program
which is the omics logic drug discovery
program
so let me take you to the program page
first
i saw that
yes update there is a cost for the
program
so if you are interested if you fill out
the form we'll be sending you all of the
details there
and you will also be able to find all
the details in the page itself
so i wanted to share again this link i
heard that somebody was having trouble
opening this link but anyways i wanted
to still show you
this program and all the details are
mentioned here so the four
sections of the program have been broken
down
into these four different phases so as
you can see that we are starting on
april 26th and this first phase will end
on the
18th of may next for transcriptomics we
are starting on may 19
and will end on 11th of june
the machine learning phase will start on
june 14th and will end on june 12th
july 12th sorry and the structural
biology
or chemo informatics will start on june
12th
and end on july 19th
and post that from 21st july to 18th
august anybody who is interested in
developing their own research project
related to drug
discovery would be able to work during
that period of time on
with the mentors to develop their own
project so
please feel free to go through this and
if you have any questions again
please reach out to us my email id is
again marketing and find out bio in case
you want to reach out regarding any of
these resources
and not just this program and for
everybody else we also have other
programs right here
so you can definitely take one of the
programs but then you can write to us
regarding this
so if a program for example okay let me
uh
first address of those questions so
these programs have been designed
keeping a syllabus in mind it's not that
each of these sessions you can come and
join any of these sessions so if you're
joining
the biomedical drug discovery workshop
you would have to take the entire
because they are designed in a sequence
which starts right at the beginning and
explains to you what are the
different things which are required it
introduces you to tools in each of the
sessions and all of these programs
actually do so each of these are
designed in a sequence
we have worked to make sure that even a
student who is a beginner but interested
in learning about
this topic can start and work their way
slowly in this four months to learn more
about drug discovery so that they also
become more confident about what they
are learning
they can gain those skills and be
introduced to new tools to new research
and work with prominent industry leaders
as well as academicians
from india who are actually
collaborating for this program
so please feel free to go through the
syllabus if you need we can send you a
brochure for the entire program that
will list out
all of the different dates for this
program and what are the different
topics which are involved and for
everybody else who are interested so we
also
have this site that we keep
page rather which we keep on updating
it's called all of the omics logic
programs so
you would have details about the omics
logic
research fellowship then we have an
upcoming
workshop with aims all india institute
of medical sciences new delhi
we have a transcriptomics program so
this is rna-seq for infectious disease
program which is starting
this week friday on april 16 and of
course the
drug discovery program so please feel
free to
reach out to us or fill out the forms in
any of these places
pages and let us know if you have any
questions
so i wanted to ask dr mohit would you
want to go ahead
and share more about the t by info
platform or do you want me to share
about it
as you are describing this it would make
more sense right
so many of you are interested in
learning what are the tools that we use
to work with these kinds of data so as
dr mohit was
talking about so these days we are
talking about
10 000 genes 20 000 genes so you need a
powerful tool
and you need to do it in a place which
does not require you
to have a very big infrastructure right
so this is what we offer through the
server t buying for platform
this is included in all of our programs
so in this platform as you can see we
have several different areas of analysis
so if you hover over one of these you
will be able to find
more about what this means and also
follows several different tutorials that
are there
so as you see in this section we have
ngs data analysis for transcriptomics
genomics and epigenetics
as well as for dna rna which includes
the metagenomics or the microbiome data
analysis
then we also have other sections on mass
spectroscopy structural biology
and more and also a section for biology
right here
so using this platform we not only
help researchers work on their own data
but we also train
our students so please feel free again
to go ahead and explore the platform and
you can also
request access details by clicking out
here and be able to fill out this form
so if you are interested we will be
sending you all the details on how to
work with this platform as well as
the videos which are related to showing
how the platform works
so now again the session is open for any
questions that you may have so please
feel free to
share your questions or post them now in
the chat box
and if there was somebody whose question
we had not
already
addressed then please post those
questions in the chat box again
so i want to thank everybody for joining
this session with us today we hope that
you enjoyed this session
and again if you need to reach out to us
please feel free to
email us with all of the different email
ids or reach out via the forms that we
have shared already
and thank you all again for attending
today's session we will be sending you
the video recording of this session via
email so please
keep a note it's marketing and fine.bio
and you can also again continue to reach
out to us via the
email addresses or the social media
groups
and thank you all again for joining
thank you again dr
harris and amber for taking the time out
of your busy schedule
to join us today
okay
okay lewis has a question about the
platform what is similar
and what is different between the tbr
and fundaments logic subscription
so any of the subscription for the
programs will give you access to the t
by info platform however
if you are looking forward to work on
your own data
we also offer a license for researchers
which starts at 99 a month but for
anybody who is starting out we offer it
for three months which is 297
so if you're interested to work on your
own data sets
we offer the research license for
anybody else who are just
looking forward to train or be part of
one of these omex logic programs or take
the courses by themselves
we have the educational license which is
included in all of our programs so that
you
automatically get access once you are
joining a program
so this is about so there's not much of
a difference it's only about
the kind of license you're using and the
data types
so thank you again for that question
and anybody interested to work on a
specific
topic please again email us
marketing and find out bios email id and
i'll be able to help you out with
reaching out to any resources and if you
again need to reach out
to any of our speakers here as well i
can help you with that
with any of the questions that you may
have so thank you all for attending
today's webinar
and i wish you all a wonderful day
thanks everyone have a good day thank
you
that if you're interested in taking a
program it would be
we would suggest that you have to take
everything in a sequence
for one of the portions so thank you all
for attending
thank you clinton